District Council
chair
thank you no substitution for them
um
Community Resources committee meeting
December
I'm going to go through them from the
pages at the bottom
page for three
four
five
six
seven
[Music]
eight
[Applause]
nine
um
can we have a proposal first of all that
they're accurate
councilor James councilor Brenton all in
favor of police show
uh one two three four
six against
abstentions two
thank you any comments to any of it
while still there
[Music]
[Applause]
page 11.
um
skate park sure amendment
has been nothing to consult on yet but
when we do have something we'll
obviously do as well request it okay
thank you
and the
oh sorry Peter that comes to Christy
all right come on YouTube yeah
um
yes the skateboard park
um councilman myself went to talk to the
gentleman who's interested in this and I
did say I will try and follow this up
this drainage aspect because
um some of us can remember seeing the
sports ground underwater and it does
worry me we're talking about a rural and
so on if it does finally go ahead and I
would like some report back from the
environment agencies about the
implications of this because it is very
important actually for the people around
that area
decision not to progress the project so
we hadn't been progressing any plans for
a wall or any other barrier of any kind
um so it's difficult
from this point it is difficult to know
which consultant on because we're not
actually progressing anything
don't just come back on that but when
Council Bushman and I went
um we were actually talking to the
gentleman about a war and I think that
is what they're going to ask for
um we know that the gentleman is going
to the Ombudsman yet again he's already
won one case against us
um it is in our planning conditions when
we pass this there would be some
amelioration in the noise so
I'm afraid just to say oh there's
nothing foreign
but I would like it to be in place for
when this comes up and we know the round
agencies overstretched because of
government Cuts I think we need to ask
them now
I think actually there is something firm
and the firm this is the decision that
you gave us not to progress a project so
we're not actually working on anything
on that site at the moment uh I think I
understand that the the residents there
are four components key components that
live and the proximity of the skate park
and they are all very upset they have
been to the Ombudsman but at the moment
we have committee resolution that tells
us not to progress the projects
so I will come back on that because it
was an original condition of the
planning it's what you can really I've
read it out the last meeting
um
and I think to look into this because we
can't just say oh you know the committee
said no I think we do need to look at it
and I mean it's only requesting somebody
else to do the work I'm not asking you
to do it through it
um and I think we ought to uh because
you know it is a very important issue
down there that if this comes up if they
filed against us again and the Amazon
says to charge a few times since my last
finding all right we'll just kicked it
out right
um it's not going to look good is it
I guess the only people who can change a
committed decision are counselors we
can't uh decide to progress a project
that you told us not to many of the
things that you uh you talk about their
cancer Christie were set out in the
report which led you to the conclusion
to do nothing we talked about the
Ombudsman complaint we talked about the
planning conditions uh we talked about
the nuisance and all those other things
so I guess that if counselors want to
reconsider that condition councilors
need to think about how they get that
back on the agenda for discussion we
can't do that
so you're saying I need to put a
proposal to full Council presumably to
do this
I'm guessing when I take advice but I'm
guessing we'll notice of motion it's
probably the only way to get this back
onto the agenda for discussion
councilor James
yeah that does trouble me a little bit
this one
um because obviously we're in Beach of
our own planning uh can make a decision
and will that come back to haunt us in
the future when people don't comply with
planning and and come back to them by
saying members you know all you've got
to do is follow your committee that we
don't need to do it and we're going
around in circles I accept haven't been
involved in it that it's very difficult
financially almost impossible certainly
physically impossible to do what we
originally plan
I don't think we can cook it keep
cooking it in the ground down the grass
personally
um I'm concerned about it
cancer bushby
thank you chair well I decide to
reinforce it
comes to the Christie has said you know
the the gentleman concerned when we had
a meeting with him he did say that he
had a further meeting with the Ombudsman
and irrespective of what the um I know
the Ombudsman doesn't have any power to
actually order towards assistant Council
to do anything and that point Wars made
but this gentleman is not going to let
this go he will take this to a judicial
review he will continue to pursue this
because he you know he convinced Molly
that he is in the right you know towards
are they are on breach of their own
planning conditions
he will continue that and I just think
well you know sometime sooner or later
we are going to have to buy the bullet
and resolve this this issue and do what
we promise to do
right at the start of this you know this
whole episode
what is the position when we haven't
complied
with a planning condition wearing breach
how do we take action against ourselves
because we should shouldn't we
sure chair you can't enforce on yourself
so the council cannot enforce on itself
so you don't take action against
yourself and I think that the the with
our full report going into all the
implications and looking at this all
over again uh we're kind of looking at
things in isolation but uh the since the
committee report there's been some
discussion around what the condition
actually said and how to discharge that
condition and the last discussion around
that was that the condition could be
discharged in retrospect it should have
been done in advance admittedly and
because of the provision of the boundary
fence at the far at the bottom of the
site was actually what was prescribed
the fact that it has no acoustic value
is irrelevant in in that planning
condition so uh I think it is very
difficult to talk about this in complete
isolation because it needs to be
discussed in the round and I sort of
thought that was what we've done before
and discounted that at the project but
uh if you're going to bring it back up
we can bring you a full report
Chancellor Bush babe thank you I think
the only sensible resolution is for also
the country to bring this back as a
little solution of which I'd be more
than happy to Second out
um you know with some more accurate and
realistic costings of what this project
would cost to actually Implement because
you know there's been some
ridiculous sums uh bounded about you
know which we're really really expensive
and I think the project could be done
for you know well under half the cost of
what we were led to believe so I think
that may well be the way forward
comes to lose me
he's shocking is the word that comes
comes to mind I know that we're playing
the game within the rules
but it's going to fall to a member of
the general public to hold this Council
to account and that seems shocking and I
certainly will support councilor
Christie in any way he can to bring it
back and I understand that we were given
costings the last time but we were
warned that they would increase because
of the the thing we were in and yes I
was party to that decision but
it's not resting easily and it shouldn't
rest easily with this Council thank you
right well I don't think well as a
community today can take this forever
Council of Christy camp and I think he's
likely to received some support
um
so let's back to the TDC staff telephone
number yeah I certainly received my copy
I trust everyone else did
so that's action must dealt with
um
the next item on the agenda is public
contributions I've had no notification
of money so that doesn't happen
Declarations of interest you will be
counselors from 94 arrests you should
know the rules by now
agreement is the agenda between Parts
one and two there is nothing suggested
for part two so that isn't a problem
urgent matters brought filled by the
chair I have nothing
item eight
high-level feasibility study on the
viability of using the cruise ship for
temporary accommodation at middle dock
Apple door
we receive to report Pages 12 to 19
and Sean is going to give you a verbal
on it
wanted to introduce his notice of motion
it's uh yeah all right
foreign
officers can always find 101 reasons why
something shouldn't be done
and in this case this sort of follows
that pattern in a way
through the report
but you have in front of you
there are not listed in 21 negatives
one which you could interpret as a
positive
I expect this in a way well I did say to
uh assume that I would do an addendum to
this but uh
unfortunately the two main people who
I've been in touch with there didn't
submit anything until last evening
actually but nonetheless very useful
because I've done some homework
I have to say first of all that most of
what we've got in front of you is
totally irrelevant check it out the
window it's completely wrong as far as
really no way are we going to put some
massive cruise ship at middle dock
however
a vessel with a capacity of about a
hundred percent is perfectly viable in
fact they do exist and the fact that the
gentleman you told me last night or
email me last night as well and talked
to one south of Rotterdam
with a three-year
yeah
I'm talking about the beanie sizes here
I don't go into a technical detail we'll
be brought to death otherwise but anyway
at the capacity of 98 persons
um
in the report it says about the
consultation with shelter for example
that's quite significant because that
was brought up to me when I when I was
interviewed all shelters hang on a
minute
the guy who did it on shelter
interesting individual I've tried to
ring him 20 times at least last week he
doesn't answer the phone the switchboard
said he's there he won't answer the
phone why
are you telling me that what shelters
said that they would be quite happy to
have people sleeping in cars as they do
in Bedford and there's one lady who does
on the new road actually
in these doorways that actually be in
some civilized accommodation
really bad that is when you look into
shelter you think well they've had a few
problems recently with their chief
executive et cetera et cetera I wonder
as a charity how well they are
performing
however we work with them speak to me so
that seems very odd as you know as I've
said before you know the first 10 years
of my life our family lived in a hobble
and then I think that I really don't
like people living a very bad
accommodation you have to do what it
takes
I've also been in touch with
Edinburgh city council and they are
progressing their cruise ship as long as
indeed are um does vote
and um
the government is a separate government
Department that deals with the refugee
element anyhow so that's taken over the
hands of a local government
so there's a there's a third party that
deal with that
they as I say and everywhere are
progressing theirs
obviously a much bigger vessel and
they're cracking on with it
now coming back to the to the report
I understand that officers have phoned
around as indeed either there's a lot of
information out there so they've picked
out stuff but much of it is not relevant
what I would propose is in fact that we
have
an island
supplementary report to this one that we
don't make a decision today where we get
further information I can certainly get
hold of some I've been in touch with
extra city council for example they're
interested but they have to go through
same procedures as we do mainly go
through a report etc etc and they
haven't done that yet because Christmas
got in the way and uh therefore
um not a lot was happening then but
there is there is information or a
possibility that we can partnership with
them and we could progress it some of
the
um stuff to do with access to the dock
of all restaurant well
that's not big stuff
my brothers in the world labor for years
and you know he was a chief petty
officer one of his jobs was to uh
arrange all this sort of stuff when they
moved alongside a place like Fort
Lauderdale were Dreadful Americans were
very very keen and even manually well
maybe you know throw all sorts of
barriers in the way in order to make uh
get more money out of the British
Columbia but it's a real deal it's all
doable so as I said I would propose that
we uh hold fire on this until I could
certainly submit more information to the
officers to
to report later
right I'm looking around councilor James
I'll come in I did support the notion at
full Council
but I've been reflected on it and of
course we've been awarded for 15
something million to get on with the
middle dot project
we um I've looked at the practicalities
of it since the suggestion and I feel
that
it's really at the end of the road we
need to concentrate on getting on with
middle dock we are looking at other
schemes to do with housing fund those
and probably later today we will be
looking at one
um
but we're not dealing with a refugee
problem at the moment which is slightly
different
also the river is very tidal so we'll
probably have to dredge it and all sorts
of things to be able to float the boats
you can't have the boats tipping over
like the ones that are tied up so I
would propose that the recipe it's not
practical and we move on and concentrate
on what we can achieve because not only
if we go out on the Middle top we would
have to get on with the Environmental
Center to be able to allow little doctor
happen as well so we're going to have
more than enough on our plate all the
next character will and I would suggest
that
her husband looked up in our situation
with metal without is Not Practical and
I would suggest we don't pursue our any
further
I would recommend that
right come on becomes a little bit
come back on that um
personally this is not intended to be
long-term
and I can't you know how long will it
take the middle dot scheme to get up and
running
because it is
oh yes I've seen the report we got uh
things in the pipeline for housing
really not a lot happens we haven't got
much there we've got the sunny and house
thing and that's already hit some snacks
as I understand it
we've got 11 sites that we were looking
at as a council many of them
non-starters you've got to get a
petition from Torrington about one of
those so you know we're talking about it
we're not doing anything that was the
point I want to make nothing
has been produced
that's the point I want to make on that
one I know it took me as you know four
years to get this cancer and do some uh
cell phones over a Stella Mary's Common
site four years nagging and moaning and
only and threatening another Housing
Association to come in and do the job
before it actually is an authority
pulled up and then did it
right two financial officer and just on
that point about not doing anything some
things are maybe a little bit less
visible so when I started this Council
we had four psls as private set to least
accommodation or release accommodation
off a landlord and place a family in
them I think it was yesterday we
probably had 13 and we're continuing to
do that so that is an invisible thing
because we're not actually building a
new property we're just taking a lease
on the property room in and obviously in
addition to solid house we're doing
hobblestone and we're done the High
Street so we've sharply quadrupled our
hostile they all come to fruition we're
not quadrupled our hostile accommodation
so it's not like nothing's being done
and probably on a personal level the
more psls would go it's probably the
easiest way of alleviating the core of
our housing problem because you're
giving family houses you know these this
cruise ship won't be family
accommodation because they won't be
cooking facilities in the
um
cabins you know because they're designed
as cruise ships aren't they so I just
think it's maybe a little not you're
maybe not aware of the psls it's quite a
significant impact on our homelessness
as we do it so we're getting more of
those psls and that's probably less
investment for the council and certainly
less
um officer time
yeah sure just didn't answer to
councilor Benton's timeline question
about middle dock so we've had the award
15.6 million Pounds
um we haven't had the offer letters
through so not digested the uh the
defined detail of it all but the program
is that we would hope to be on site
later this year with a conclusion of the
project in 2025 so it is quite a tight
development timer on that one
councilor Hudson
thank you chair I'm happy to second
councilor James's motion and I didn't
support it the first time but I'm always
prepared to listen to valuable or valid
arguments
the issue for us is I was once quoted as
not liking the term a small Authority
but we are a small authorities as far as
capacity is concerned and we are to be
congratulated on our 15.6 million we
need to focus on what we're doing
we do not need to go chasing what might
be we have plans and progress to add to
our housing Supply we are exploring more
we've just mentioned the pods for single
people we are exploring those as well
and we are getting additional ground
funding now to me let's do things and
let's do them well
don't let's just
deviate from our vision
and I commend David Benton for councilor
Benton for coming up with an idea but we
are a small Authority the places he
mentions have lots of staff
and are actually targeting a different
employee group it was mentioned at the
meeting where this was passed that there
could be
um would be problems with mixing people
together from all different walks of
life families single people and how you
actually manage the situation in a very
confined space
and that for me was one of the major
challenges the other logistical
challenges of having a boat there what
do we do with it when we finish with it
etc etc I think it's all far too much
for this Council to take on and I
commend let's do the things we've got
funding for do it well and actually make
sure we share with our communities what
we are doing
thank you
so your second instance yes
everyone else wishing to speak oh sorry
counselor
chair thank you um I supported councilor
Benton's motion to come to this
committee
um because it was a fresh idea and I
think I used the word looking out the
box
um that wasn't that I necessarily
supported the actual proposal but I
supported the idea that it should we
should have a first look at it with a
bit more detail having seen a first pass
on that detail and I hear what councilor
Benson says about he would want to bring
more information to the discussion but
um
exactly as councilor Hudson just said
the the
within our remit and within our capacity
this is a step too far I think both
financially and also
um the pure organization of it is also
risks complicating a major project that
we've never just got
um lined up funding-wise and I don't
think you know we're
be doing anything to try to complicate
what is
um going to be a major project and and
it's just too close both location
timeline
Etc
um and uh sorry I'm afraid that I I
would no longer support further officer
time on this proposal
Council of those
yes I supported it too
and
I don't change my mind on the principle
it's housing you see that we can always
ask locally about the parking branches
the message that you've got out there we
have along with many authorities a
housing devices
and yes
we all
exceed the opportunity of a fresh
thought
two two
that it is what it is
a housing crisis we have we're going to
have villages with no young people in it
you know it can't go wrong
the chief is depth wants to speak on
this one uh thanks Jay just uh in
response to councilor laws about the
other authorities sorry dude uh
circulate uh after the motion was
approved to other Chief Executives
across Devon and there was no interest
coming back how he spoke directly to the
chief executive Exeter because
councilman referred uh Exeter as being
interested and the chief executive
didn't know anything that helps the
project when I hadn't heard of it within
Exeter
all right
[Music]
well
um
okay I've obviously spoken to the um
lead member of portfolio of extra
and then he is putting it to his his
group
this week actually so I mean actually
you've got to remember experts run by
the members all right it's a member
Authority they they decide policy then
there so that's that's quite a
significant
input on that
right
no one else wishing to speak oh
counselor Pennington as a non-member of
the committee
um
I mean it's an amazing figure and I did
ask the question we have a special
budget meeting I think a week ago about
all these bits of your way and The
Business of course is 1.5 to 2 million
thank you Jeff so that sum is to sum for
the The Works to the key water it's not
just the survey costs but that's the the
key wall repair Works
um and that sun's been arrived at by uh
civil engineers surveying and coming up
with cost estimates on on that piece of
work
it's a big sea world
right I have a proposal and a secondary
from councilor James
that I think was sympathetic to The
Proposal it isn't a worker for college
at this time
and we should
put it back in the file I think would
describe it past
those in favor of that attitude please
show
one two three four five six seven eight
whereas again it comes to the problem
very persuasive cancer problem but I can
see why it's gone wrong
thank you for your efforts
right we move on from there
oh God newspapers
do I Tim
number nine
the removal of burial restriction for
members of the community with an Islamic
faith
who's doing this one sure okay so but
we're back in 2019 uh members debated uh
Muslim burials and and dedicated an area
of higher Cemetery in Biddeford for
Muslim bearers
um that's fine and we've had two cents
so that's been received well
um one of the uh restrictions that was
placed on it at that time was that it
was only for Muslims who are resident in
torrage and a review of our sort of the
qualities policy and relating to this
has led us to the the knowledge that
that is the only restrictive so that
restriction only applies to the errors
of Muslim faith it doesn't apply to any
other Faith burials so Christian or
otherwise
um and so the question is is that uh
fair and should we change the policy to
make Muslim burials on the same basis as
any other burial in higher cemetery and
that's the recommendation that's pretty
foreign
are we going to have capacity for our
local Muslims
I don't know the answer to those
questions so I couldn't find them and
let them let you know it doesn't help
debate but I don't know the capacity of
them
it was very little piece but but the
side up the top side wasn't there
I've got no problem with it I've just
had practicalities and also assessing
the report you've got dig deeper and
stuff like that so you know there will
be additional cost on that side
okay
thank you Council of laws I'll move it
chat thank you moved seconded by
councilor James
foreign
thank you
i210
taxi life provision on beautiful key car
park
a nice Old Chestnut
professor today
um so I think 2019 uh an eventful year
of Community Resources most centrality
set up a welcome group to review uh taxi
provision in town uh Chris worked with
that working working group and the
recommendation was made to Community
Resources around a number of different
things one of those being that the need
for additional ranking at that time and
the problem was that it was practically
impossible to find additional ranking
space the considered that what was
proposed is set out in the report which
was to create a taxi Bank on the hard
standing the concrete plinth of the key
car parts with uh
the taxis able to enter the entrance of
the car park rank on the concrete blend
and then do a U-turn and come back out
of the entrance of the car park to
during the taxi rank as and when so kind
of feeder to that right at the time
um you will see that there was some
concern from your car park manager and
from the environmental health manager
with the health and safety
considerations of that proposal and
since that time there's been a
significant shift in the requirement for
ranking
um because there's less taxis in town
and less demand so what we wanted to do
was put this back on the table because
we've got a minute from from CNR to
implement this scheme to say actually is
this time to reconsider this is there
really requirements to do it and do you
still want us to do it
um Chris is here you can ask the answer
you any questions about the specific
taxi elements of this obviously I know a
fair bit about the car park I've managed
it for several years and we do have some
quite significant concerns about health
and safety of the arrangement thank you
thank you chair well I was one of the
councilors and I sit on the licensing
Committee of tourist district attorney
[Music]
um
must be three years ago now at least
three years ago I'd imagine uh and it
went through seeing how I went through
four Council she should have been
implemented the only reason that wasn't
implemented
as far as I'm aware apparently there was
some signage which required to be put up
so that when the taxis have entered uh
the copper and then turned rain uh in
the widest part of that key area by the
uh part of the High Street there so that
they sit up sit on the concrete there
was some
um
signage that was required of the exit
because you're not allowed to exit from
that area
so the sound if you would have to read
something like taxis only can exit this
you know from this area oh generation
I'm sure it would have done it should
have done three years ago we would then
have had three years of operation to see
exactly how well it was or how well it
didn't work etc so I'm just I haven't
really that it's taken this long for
anything to to happen I I've already
just started that but here it is up on
the agenda again
is accurate in saying that this decision
was taken in 2019 uh I think it was
November 2019.
um so there were a number of things I
don't think were factored into the
original
um discussions and there were subtle
complications around the parking order
and how do you educate an area within
the car park for parking when you the
order says there's no parking those
sorts of things with debates about that
then in early 2020 covid hit and this
became a very low priority initiative
there were lots of other things to do at
that time uh our availability to look at
this as an option has come about and
that's why it's back in front of you I
guess the point is we've looked at the
changed environment do we still need to
do it that's the question
uh come back onto the bus but yes
that's right
yes
to stop those taxis when the rank is
full from you know Motoring in and
around amount of car park and other
parts of the uh you know the key side to
actually join the bank and to me it
still makes total sense
for them to be directed into the car
park apart on that seat on that concrete
plane obviously you can't do this when
the key is shut when there's a ship
that's you know it could be in you know
that day or a following day and that was
taken into consideration but that
doesn't happen very many times it is to
me to me it's a clear area that
yeah it makes it makes total sense to
use that because it protects the Clutter
away from other parts of the key
particularly manifold bar you've got
cars merging under the key to join the
taxi rank if they use if this proposal
was implemented literally they come out
of the
car park you know the Riverside copper
off the concrete plinth or the blue
crane sets and literally just feed into
the right one at a time as space is
available it makes perfect sense and you
know
I don't think there's an awful and not a
need I mean it's all it's hard as car
parts we can make we make the rules up I
don't see where there's going to
necessarily need to be any uh special
traffic orders or something like that to
actually implement the site I mean it
could be done even if he did it on a
six-month trial basis through the summer
just to see how it worked the cost
implications are next to nothing it's
just a matter of conveying the message
to the taxi drivers themselves and say
you know A variation in the license is
they now have to use that area as a
feeder rank
I think in perfect sense to try it let's
even let's try it for six months so you
can hold up
come to the question
thank you I disagree uh Council bushby
and I'm going to repeat what I said when
this first came up
um we have a fantastic Riverside
absolutely beautiful you can go to other
towns you don't even know the rivers
there Barnstable it's a classic example
but we had this fantastic Riverside and
you go to other towns and if they had
this would they use it as a car park
I don't think they would they would
actually really use it to regenerate the
town you look at the map we've been
given and what I said when this was
first proposed was you've got the taxis
on the road behind that you've got cars
and now you're suggesting another row of
taxis you've got three lines of cars
between
the people of Biddeford and their River
I'm afraid I just cannot accept that I
know when the whole key scheme was built
was it 13 years ago now I actually tried
to get all the cars removed off the key
of the world all right so what but to
actually put more colors on the killer
I'm afraid is silly and you talk to any
other Clan anywhere else and that offers
well you've got this beautiful keysight
and you're just putting more and more
flowers on it on certainly but I think
we should remove this line of taxes
councilor Hudson
um my memory doesn't take me back I
don't think to 2019 and I do seem to
recall having this discussion about
where taxes went and there were several
options on the table my concern is that
this is a rule for the taxi drivers only
and not uh normal car users now I often
have reason to park in our car park here
now it's quite clearly marked that you
can't exit at the bottom
how many times in the last few months
have I seen people whizzing out there
because they think they can get out
quicker
I fear for
um we are a holiday and tourist area and
people who aren't familiar with the fact
there's one rule for taxes there might
be signage
like the signage over there are they
going to follow it are there going to be
accidents and I wondered if that have
been risk assessed in the original
report maybe the impact of our car park
here wasn't taken into consideration I
don't know uh that's my question to Sean
really and I'm sorry I didn't ask it
before today
so thank you so um thank you chair uh so
I I think Loosely have been risk
assessed and and I think it was verbally
conveyed by uh the the manager of the
time
um but I'm not sure there was a formal
risk assessment on that it was certainly
a concern from a car park management
perspective you know the Civil
enforcement officers have great concerns
that you have a counter flow in the car
park with herringbone parking and cold
Vehicles reversing into it uh we we used
to allow for ranking uh waiting to rank
on the Fisherman's Wharf element but
that became abused because the taxi
drivers were whizzing their ground and
we had one of our own councils report
that had almost been knocked over there
in fact two of the council said Council
I mean Amber golf had reported that they
would have several accidents there so it
was that that became a bit of a health
and safety uh hot spot in the car park
were there any serious accidents thank
the Lord no
um but it was something that it was
certainly a concern at that time but the
formal risk assessment note thank you
cancer James well very briefly I was
chair of the licensing committee when we
first discussed this we decided we were
creating a hazard by loan taxes to go in
and turn around and come back out in
effect I look at the map and I'm still
confused when I look at the map because
there seems to be red arrows going
everywhere but
I used to do planning in one form of
life but I just want to make it clear
that when we did look at it 2019 2020 is
that we've took in serious accounts of
the the dangers of you know and they
still do it taxes will go in the in and
turn around straight out and we were
trying to stop that happening but by
doing what is proposed we're sort of
creating that situation anyway but I
don't know a solution he spent two or
three years looking at it so that's all
I've got the extra
Council of laws
I totally agree with councilor Christie
and I'll take him back to uh 1990
something early 90s
but if it was even then starting to
decline and there were several of us
that felt it should get a resort status
that we should clear the key completely
of cars
at that that Riverside is he said it's
so visible it should be a wonderful it's
certainly not a place for taxis to get
the word back in so you let me carry on
um it didn't work but if you look at
that Riverside and then think of someone
like Lugano what they would have through
there
a place for the people to Promenade used
to be a Promenade now you're talking
about putting more cars on it
I can't support more cars but I think
that when we get another leveling up
opportunity
don't look at that part look at what
you've got
there thank you chair
no one else wishing to speak right what
propositions have I got
nothing too far from my template
those that we don't allow the taxis to
use this concrete right
and you've got a second there with
Council of laws
on the other side of the coin is there
anyone going to propose opposite
well okay we'll put counselor Christie's
proposal to the room those in favor of
it please show
seven
against
one obsessions one
right
item 11
local Authority housing fund
David
yes I guess
Oh Stacy sorry it's me thank you chair
um first of all apologies that there
isn't a written report before you
just to make it clear we're just gonna
safe and principal members agree
on the proposal I wanted to put a
written report before you I was waiting
um for some information from the finance
team but as you can appreciate Finance
are busy preparing the budget reports
ready for CNR and and full Council and
with all of these funding opportunities
that come forward they come forward late
and we have to jump fairly quickly so
um this originally came to terminal the
21st of December unfortunately I was on
leave and that that at that time and but
we need to make an initial
um indication to government about
whether we want to proceed or Not by
this Wednesday
um
I think
um we would have to come forward with
some further details of members reminded
and some financial information because
they're all invariably
um mean College will need to to burrow
but effectively I think members will be
familiar with the Ukraine scheme um that
has been ongoing and we have
um a fair few Ukraine families within
College currently I'm currently residing
with um hosts which is great
um we I'm sure we'll also be aware from
the news of the Afghan resettlement
scheme
um and the government's keenness to
remove them from their hotel Vision
accommodation to find a permanent
accommodation and we currently have no
one within turbo agenda the Afghan
scheme but
what the government is proposing is a
fairer fund of 500 million
um for the financial years 22 23 and 23
24. we've told just proposed allocation
being 576 600 pounds
um year one we would receive 172
000 and we're at two we would receive
403
000 now the the fund objectives are to
assist those under the Afghan Ukraine
schemes and provide them with long-term
accommodation
um the government recognizes that um
towards alongside many Council areas
already face huge pressures um in
relation to homelessness and therefore
the proposed fund is to help mitigate
those those pressures
so if
even for the money we can use it
um quite flexibly actually we can
refurbish or convert any buildings that
we currently have within our ownership
and that's whether it's residential or
non-residential or use it to bring
dilapidated properties back into use we
can acquire Properties or acquire new
builds we can use it for modular housing
and Council owned sites uh and we can
use it to work with other organizations
such as housing authorities
um but the the major condition with the
funding is that we would be expected to
increase I say increase we haven't made
a pledge currently
um to support people under the Afghan
resettlement scheme
um so we're to be required to house
Afghans and should they want to settle
in the towage area but I think the major
the respiratory perspective is um once
they have finished using the
accommodation and we can retain the
accommodation following homelessness
cohort and of course even if we put a
bid in and it doesn't necessarily
guarantee
um that we they would resettle in in the
tollage area
so effectively it is a mechanism by
which we can use it for our own housing
um obviously we already have some sites
some going we you know we have Sally
house
um we have the modular units coming
there there's a potential and we could
potentially
um have further
um units um from we haven't
um looked at a scheme yet because we
haven't had the time but if members in
principal want us to go ahead then
obviously we can come forward later on
with the schemes
um and the financial information
um but we have to the key critical point
is we have to go back to the government
by this Wednesday and to say whether we
are willing to accept
um the funding and the condition that we
increase our our birds so we don't have
um a huge amount of time
um I know there's been a lot in the
Press about the timelines for the
funding but we haven't got to go to
government with a worked up scheme by
Wednesday we've just got to give an
indication whether we would be happy to
um and if we don't accept the funding
um the funding will be reallocated to
other local authorities who are willing
to I'm obviously happy to take any
questions
councilor James
I'm quite happy to propose that we keep
ahead there's slightly less money than I
I thought originally
um but
I'm happy to propose a principle okay
yeah councilor Hudson well I'm more than
happy to Second this because it is an
opportunity for this Authority
um a little bit so we need to look at
short-term Solutions and we need to look
at longer term Solutions the properties
would return to us if we'd housed
ukrainians and pray God the war comes to
her conclusion and they they return home
they become our assets
um to it was mentioned or alluded to
that we would have to borrow
but if we can set our rental income for
these properties at a reasonable amount
to cover our interest costs on our loans
then I think this is a win-win situation
for everyone
um we have a duty uh I think we would be
foolhardy not to accept it
they offer and put a proposal together
because if we miss the boat and then it
we have numbers have forced upon us
oh very sorry missed the boat that was a
bad chest
missed the opportunity I wonder why he
was laughing
um it will miss the opportunity it
doesn't come back uh it's an expression
of Interest with some detail and I I
think we will welcome a fuller report on
how we're going to do it and how we're
going to approach it and every other
authority who's having the same offer
put on the table is having those
discussions and I'm sure we will work in
partnership with other authorities to
find out how they're approaching the
situation
thank you oh I second the motion
councilman
okay you didn't want to buy a gin or
anything
thank you
this doesn't sit very easily with me
because for a number of reasons I mean
some time ago we've already declared a
housing emergency for all local people
we've got 70 71 finalists that are
desperately in need of accommodation
here
[Music]
and what does it look to our local
community when we're applying for money
to be able to convert buildings that we
may or may not own or whatever to then
be given this accommodation to
Afghan families for you know Ukraine as
well as much simply as I've got for
those fantastic to do all that if you if
you have spare capacity we haven't got
enough capacity let alone any spare
that's my real concern where is it you
know the money that we talk about the
grants that we can apply for
you know they're nothing in reality I
mean we know the cost of converting some
of the house you know is far more than
what you know this this Grand funding
would be to purchase sellers do the
conversion and that's only a very a
small unit you're talking quite a lot of
units in order to meet the the kind of
requirements that will be expected of us
so
I would think very very carefully before
councilor James
I'm sorry child I can't accept that
argument at all because there's we're
being offered money to house originally
it will be
um
oh sorry
um
sorry
I'm sorry I went over my head the
ukrainians experience and the auction
that once we've done that we can use
those hoses should they become available
again for our own people you know and
also we've got ukrainians living in
families and they're always well it's
been extended now to a year and the
money's been extended but if they become
um homeless they then fall on us that
we've got to hold them and we've got to
finance that ourselves because as you
know we only get 93 pounds a week or
something for housing families and it's
costing us you know four times that so
it is a no-brainer you know I've spent
20 years holding it holding local people
and trying to do particularly youngsters
and I'll take every opportunity that is
practical to do so and this to me is a
no-brainer we move forward you know and
I can't accept that because we've
accepted them here as refugees and then
just say well we can't we don't have a
whole new hope you were going to lose
your homeless they'll become our problem
anyway then the government's office
money to help do it and I know through
the two so we are looking at
opportunities all the time and Adrian
Redwood has had the sort of the Merit
you know the um the the instruction or
instruction but to suggestion that we
keep looking and if he comes against our
own properties that we can look at we
pursue it and we could just go be
positive in terms of push me I'm sorry
member
[Music]
thank you chair uh just part of
Christmas
there was a group of I think it's
refugees from the clearing centers up in
Kent Jones of
North Devon District house who didn't
know anything at all about that movement
from the whole office it was a deal done
by the home office at the private hotel
and I think this is an improvement from
that situation that the home office is
no deal with you I think it is a home
office that's funding this money
um so I think it's an improvement
second layer just a little bit concerned
because you gave the paper it to your
previous about local need and and the
the follow-through on look we need for
our duty to house how can you mix the
two together because there's going to be
very
different lines of requirements of both
our illuminates how soon as we do it for
a dug set or coaching bushby said about
the 71 families and what obviously is
going to be terms and conditions that
will be attached to the people placed
and but yeah I do accept there's a huge
need there
foreign
we're not necessarily looking at mixing
them together and with this current
funding
um they're predominantly asking us to
provide homes for larger families so it
would be an isolated
um property not within our current
temporary accommodation stock or it may
you know so
um
as councilor James has said
um with the ukrainians
we've been very fortunate actually in
terms of the relationships between the
sponsors and guests have been very good
and we were
preparing potentially for a lot of
breakdowns which in relationships but
that hasn't happened but they are able
to present to us as an authority for
housing anyway and if that happened we
would be under a duty and the good thing
about this current project is we are
absolutely desperate for larger
properties to house our current families
so if we could have the funding to have
a larger property that we could use
later on it would be fantastic
there's a chair
potentially possibly I'll come back to
okay just for clarification then
I think I just heard this right so if
the Ukrainian family presented itself to
torch we didn't have the duty to house
them what is it whenever I use this same
old enough okay about people that moved
in from Liverpool or you know Manchester
or whatever move into a bit of an area
I'm almost told by the officers no we've
got no duty to house them because
they're not tolerate residents
and that already has been put today on
numerous occasions that exactly that
exact scenario that I've said because we
do get an awful lot of people move down
from other parts of this you know the UK
because you know
college is a lovely partner that all of
the country to live in and you know it's
it's far better than to live here in
some ways than there's or Manchester and
I'm always told that is not the place we
we have no responsibility to tell them
so why is it different for someone
coming in from overseas
or something
the legislation is set out so with the
ukrainians if they came straight to
Thomas they are given the same rights
and obligations as any other college
residents so that's the same with
obtaining a job obtaining benefits and
the housing Duty in the notion to
families as a whole
that's the local connection criteria so
local connection can be family within
the area come to the area worked within
the area within a Saturn for years so if
for example they are in Liverpool and
they've had no previous connection to
Toleration toridge don't have a duty if
they have because they've grown up in
college or they've got a family
connection here that we make that we may
have a duty but you know I totally
understand your your frustration but
we're hamstrung by the legislation as as
it set out and under these settlement
um regimes they have been given that
that right
counseling my apologies for not calling
me that's all right
um just to follow on that last one these
these people have Refugee status
um I know it can be pretty tough up
there but people coming down from
Liverpool right now to attract the
status of being refugees uh and they've
put them in a completely different
um
Place really
it's the easiest the easiest decision is
to put up the drawbridge and say no
however
we have to be a generous caring and
inclusive community
it's easy to turn around and say we
shouldn't have a four day budget and
that we shouldn't help anybody anywhere
else and it happens all the way down
right down to our local communities or
it's a government giving foreign aid
across the world to different things it
all comes from the same generous Spirit
of heart and actually a preparedness to
accept that we are a wider Community
than just ourselves wherever we are
um I would say to say no not here in
effect not in my backyard uh culturally
is a very dangerous position to take
princess James sorry to keep coming back
uh trying to think when
um and it would be 15 years ago when
this this
officer there and we worked on the the
affordable housing group worked with
officers on the walls now the government
wide doesn't have a choice
and if you look at it there was fairly
strict rules about how people are housed
We Can't Stop people coming down even
buying houses that's one of the big bug
bars we got more than people moving down
here not in housing you know because the
first room is creating the problems for
the second ones but there are quite
strict rules about within Devin Home
Choice and every operator and Stacy
knows how we've been having bowls even
going to how difficult it is within
those Halls for young couples local ones
to qualify on the ABCD list to get a
house so if you come from away and you
you haven't got the the employment
record the family record it is very very
difficult so we're not housing
um you know people from Manchester I
know I suffer that abuse and wholesale
when we were building affordable homes
because one of our directors until first
two lecture at Salford and it doesn't
happen we're bending over backwards to
look after our own people and this
scheme will not affect that what it will
do is give us some home base to improve
our own people at later dates if those
houses become available
so it's a no-brainer okay you have a
debate I'm going to put it to the vote
those in favor please show
helped against
well let's say
foreign
[Music]
comments to it
yes councilor Christie yeah I see
um in March meeting we've got the um
ideas for the library
um from Sean I think I'm looking forward
to those
um but can I ask
um do we have any time scale for when
um getting their reps I think they're
downstairs aren't they
um when they're going to actually leave
when will this building become empty
again
I don't know uh it's the honest answer
to that one I'd need to go back and ask
the guys
um what the plan is because obviously it
depends on their conversion of the the
art center that they're doing so I don't
know what the timeline is on there and
in terms of the new ideas report that's
something that's coming out of a number
of different strands of work which I
know you're involved in a bit of a
regeneration stuff
um and I need to see where Chris is
pulling that together
[Music]
is that when we left this building empty
before
just look up there you can see the
problems this building has
um and I think we do need to really
progress as fast as we can just before
the building starts to fall down
cancel your laws are talking of
buildings falling down when dire need of
a First-Class
property for the archive the archive
deserves something like the old library
come the archive be considered in
Insurance report please as a possibility
sure you can consider it surely
yeah
history chair I'd like it to be taken
seriously thank you counselor
well I was actually involved in setting
up the archives back in
1980s
um yeah it would be great but we were
given um a visit a walk around both this
building and the library some time ago
some of the councilors and The Stumbling
point about putting the archive there is
um we were told that that library has to
be economically viable
um the only problem was that obviously
the archive is a boundary thing it's got
no money or so
um and the other thing is maybe we could
think
what would go into the library I mean
it's a very specialized very unusual
building
um I know this is why you know I'm
looking forward to Sean's report
um seeing all these ideas but it is a
very difficult building to think what
who would want it who would pay us money
to use it it's going to be very
difficult
Sean tool
okay there we go we look forward to that
any other comments or I'm going to
declare the meeting closed
at
the level of nine I just need to call
thank you